Drake is ready to call it it's cursed
against sports teams is over so Drake
was courtside once again for the trying
to wrap their game last night and fans
thought that meant trouble cuz Drake has
a reputation of causing sports teams or
athletes to lose when he's at the game
or he poses with pitches with them or
wears their Jersey yeah Toronto Maple
Leaf fans thought the curse was going
strong when Drake popped up it gained
for the least series against Boston and
then the Leafs lost well Drake was at
the Raptors game last night
they won apparently being very aware of
this rate curse TSN reporter Josh Lewin
Berg tweeted Drake to the media on his
way out of the building you want me to
talk about the curse or you guys good so
the Drake might be off the hook
no but now people are pointing to the
Biebs no so justin bieber and haley
headed to Boston last night to watch the
Leafs for Game seven and they lost so
now there might be a Bieber curse no
it's Drake no no no the thing about
Drake is that he's well aware of this
right and what I don't like is the
trolling I don't like him showing up at
the Leafs game wearing the sweater right
that's the problem oh because that was a
huge that's a huge doing he knew what he
was doing and he was trolling and that's
what I don't like like why do that to
people even says he's trying to be
relevant to everything Drake's so
exhausting really yeah and also we're
gonna need a little more than one Raptor
win to prove that there's no curse I'm
sorry your record proves otherwise bro
Texas says does one game make a curse or
break it no neither look at history